Okej, finns det någon annan detalj som är såhär, här är bara de där som verkligen bryr sig om skor.
Är det såhär, ja, skor snörerna blänker i mångljuset.
Finns det någon udda detalj som man inte hade kunnat tänka sig?
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dessbra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då säger vi välkommen till podden Emil Jansson från Skolyx.
Tack så mycket.
Det är lite podddebut för dig.
Ja det är det.
Känner du dig nervös?
Ja lagom tror jag.
Kul, utmaning.
Ja, det brukar bli bäst när det är folk som är lite nervösa, för då bryr de sig om vad de säger.
De som är för rutinerade skiter lite i detta.
Ja det gör jag också.
Det är bra.
Nu ska vi ta alla dina hemligheter och ge dina konkurrenter allt du kan.
Ajamen, kör på.
För de som inte känner till skolyx kan vi börja med, vad är det för någonting?
Vi säljer skor och skovård, kvalitetsskor och kvalitetsskovård kan man säga.
Och är väl en av de största i Norden på det då.
Så när du ser en människa som mig som vars primära fokus på skor är att man ska kunna dra på dem utan att snöra.
Jag hade ju uppskattat om sådant som barn har.
Vad heter det?
Karlborgband.
Jag hade önskat att det fanns.
Ni jobbar inte så mycket med det.
Det är ju mitt mål att hitta sådana skor.
Kan du känna ett lätt frakt för sådana människor som mig?
Nej, absolut inte.
Vi har ju tvärtom, så det är en utmaning att tillgodose det.
De jag har på mig idag till exempel det är ju sådana elastiska snören, ett par skor från Swinster som bara är att dra av och på.
Sen har vi mycket Loafers och sådant.
Det är också samma koncept men man behöver ju kanske då förstå lite.
Det är väl det som är utmaningen då att nå ut kanske förutom de som är mest initierade, spridade utanför en ganska nischad känsla.
Du menar att ni riktar inte bara mot de här extrema, jag vet inte om man kallar det skornördar, eller finare människor, utan ni försöker faktiskt få in sådana som mig.
Initialt var det mycket skornördar och skofolk som var väldigt insatta, men sen har det breddats mer och mer.
Så nu är det ju min dotters kompis här, och min dotter som är 12-årsåldern.
Så det är väldigt, väldigt brett idag.
Det är ju en bred målgrupp.
Jag tänkte ju, man 45 år jobbar på bank.
Ja men första åren var det nog det.
Och sen märkte vi att framförallt de pratade lite skovart på nyhetsmorgon en dag.
Och då märkte vi att det smalt till i butiken.
Och då var det fullständigt brett från unga herrar till äldre damer och allt möjligt.
Och sen dess har det, det är ju främst som du säger, kanske män 20-40 men alla möjliga finns det.
Okej, ja då fattar jag.
Ja kul att ni har så bred målgrupp och att du inte hatar mig trots att jag ser ut som jag gör, uppskattar jag.
Gör du ändå en liten bedömning av människor när de kommer in och träffar dig?
Gör du en liten sån här, ja det är en sån där skomänniska.
Både och.
Man måste vara ärlig i denna.
Ja men jag är ärlig men jag kommer ihåg en av de första, vi är ju utifrån en del trangelser när man är på mini-mässor där det samlas olika skoltillverkare.
Och det var verkligen första gången jag var ut och sålde utanför nätet och träffade kunder.
Och det kunde komma killar i, som kanske inte var den typiska skogköparen, men som definitivt, de visste exakt vad de var ut efter och så köpte de två finskor utan att blinka, bara ville prova storlek och gick därifrån.
Så det går egentligen inte att generalisera på det sättet.
Sen kan man ju se om någon.
Men det man främst kanske ser är att vissa har en riktigt skitskostym kanske, och så har de helt glömt skorna.
Och då ser man att någon har en väldigt hög ambitionsnivå.
Men missat på något sånt som vi tycker av i förmedlaren som är så lätt som skorna, att hade man bara toppat upp med det.
Så det är nästan en större grej.
Eller det är det man kanske reagerar på mer, att man vill nå ut och hjälpa till när det är den lilla detaljen som kan höja allt annat så mycket.
Jag fattar inte alls.
Detta är inte alls min värld.
Det är därför jag tycker det är intressant att vara här idag.
Det ligger så långt från mitt bekvämlighet som råder detta.
Jag köper alla mina kläder på Märkös yrkeskläder i 40-pack.
Och alla mina skor köps samma år efter år efter år.
Jag googlar bara på samma modell.
Så jag tycker det här är väldigt intressant.
Vi sitter ju i någon sorts...
Är detta någon sorts showroom eller testlandskap här?
Det är ju bara massa skor i olika nyanser och med olika snören.
Jag är ju livrädd för att spilla mitt kaffe på någonting för jag vet ju inte vad någonting kostar.
Nej men det är vårt showroom här som vi har.
Vi ligger hyfsat nära flygplatsen så det är många som ska in till stan och sådär som kikar förbi på vägen.
Och då har vi så att man kan boka möte här då och komma och testa.
Då har vi så att du kan testa ut allt och titta på allting.
Sen har vi vårt lager på annan ort då men du kan testa ut allt här och lära dig allting.
Är det från grunden ett enormt skointresse från dig eller är det från början e-handel, business och så blev det skor av misstag?
Ja det är e-handel och business från början.
Okej, du är inte skornörd från början?
Nej, jag är inte.
Det var oväntat.
Jag har nog börjat, jag tror redan det var 1997 eller att jag började med mobilskalen på gymnasietiden.
Hade man kört på med det i All In så hade man ju haft ett jättedrag säkert.
Jag testade ett massa olika projekt och sen så jobbade jag länge på Telia, 20 år ungefär, men vid sidan om så fanns det där intresset hela tiden.
Så var det någon gång...
20 år?
Hur gammal är du?
Jag är drygt 40, 43.
Jaha okej, japp.
Så jag drog igång massa projekt hela tiden och testade olika grejer och så där.
Men så sa en polare någon gång att du är grym på att testa och dra igång saker men du slutför ju aldrig någonting ordentligt.
Och just då hade jag börjat det här med skottillbehör och skovård och kände att nu får jag ge det här en rejäl chans.
Och på den vägen är det lite, då körde jag på och så kände jag att nu får det bära eller brista.
Okej, men kan du idag känna ett stort intresse för skor eller är det fortfarande businessaspekten som är det intressanta?
Nej men nu är det ju helt annat.
Nu när man har kommit in i den världen lite.
Sen har jag ju kanske inte ett av mina grundintressen i livet.
Alltså det är inte det jag lägger helst min fritid på.
Men nu är jag ju definitivt skointresserad och ganska skokundig.
Eller mer skokundig än de allra flesta.
Är du mer skokundig än dina kunder?
De som kommer hit och testar, känner du att du håller dig apart med dem?
Eller är de ofta mer nördiga än vad du är?
Nej, jag är ju väldigt, väldigt nördig.
Så jag är kanske topp två procent.
Men sen finns det ju topp en procent som en kollega då till exempel.
Som lägger semestern på och tittar på skor och så där.
Det är det jag inte riktigt har.
Din kollega är, nu kommer jag att tog vad han heter.
Jesper.
Det är han som har någon sorts skoblogg eller, han har till och med en skopodd.
Han har allt möjligt med skor kan man säga.
Han har en skopodd och han har en blogg, då Showgazing heter den.
Han arrangerar VM i skoputsving i New York.
Det är ju underbart.
Varje höst åker han till Japan en vecka för att titta på skor och träffa skomakare i Japan.
Har du varit med på detta någon gång?
Ja, jag har varit med på, vi ställer ut och säljer skor och så det har vi gjort både i London och New York på de här då.
Det är helt knäppt.
Men ja, hur många lyssnar, för den här podden är väl på svenska?
Engelska.
Hur många lyssnar på den här skopodden vet du det?
Jag har inte koll riktigt, det är ju hans egen då, man kan sälja sig den om då så att den har jag inte stenkoll på.
Det hade bara varit intressant att veta hur många människor följer en podd vars stora fokus är skor.
Ja, men det är nog mer än man tror och framförallt så är det väldigt spritt runt om i världen också.
Det reser ju folk till New York från Japan och Europa och för att titta på skor och tävla i skor.
Ja det är helt knäppt.
Kan du uppleva att han ibland suckar lite åt din okunskap?
Vi båda tycker väl kanske ofta att vi har rätt sådär i olika saker så det kan ju bli lite sådana här diskussioner när vi tycker att jag kan ha sett något som jag tycker jag tycker vi ska ta in och så tycker han något annorlunda och så samma sak tvärtom, att han kan ta in något som jag tycker det är alldeles för smalt.
Nu nischar du in det.
Men samtidigt så är det ju inte så att det är något avgörande utan då testar vi ofta, upplever jag i alla fall om du frågar mig, jag vet inte om du frågar honom, men då kan vi testa saker som jag tycker eller som han tycker och så ser vi hur det går helt enkelt.
Så det är nog, jag tycker det är en bra balans.
Men det är du som äger bolaget så att...
Den som bestämmer tycker alltid det är en behaglig balans.
Du tar den inputen du behöver, vad fint har du?
Jag förstår.
Men om jag ska sammanfatta det så är Skolyxet i grunden e-handelsbolag som säljer skor och skotillbehör i premiumsegmentet.
Ja, exakt.
Och de tillbehören ni säljer är olika sorter skoblock men ni har även gallgar och ni har lite olika putts...
Skovård och klädvård kan man säga.
Så det är ju mest till skor men sen även lite gallgar och garderobstillbehör och sådär.
Men huvudsaken är ju skovård och klädvård kan man säga.
Och sen hade ni en liten nice touch här.
Vi kollade på en sån gravyrmaskin som ni hade som stod igång och gjorde initialer på...
Och gallgar var det i det här fallet.
Ja precis.
Både gallgar och skoblock och sådär kan du få graverat om initialer eller namn eller logotype eller vad man vill.
Ja.
Jag tyckte bara det var en kul liten detalj som man tagit när den sticker ut från andra försäljare inom det här området.
Jag gissar att det finns en del...
Det måste ändå finnas rätt många konkurrenter inom skor.
Ja, det finns ju mängder.
Det finns ju allt från väldigt stora multi-brand-stores som har mängder med märken.
Sen har vi ju nischade även konkurrenter både i Sverige och i Utanland som har just skor.
Det som gör oss unika skulle jag säga är ju mixen, att vi kan liksom erbjuda hela skospektrat med skovård och skor, liksom med väldigt hög kvalitet vård och plus att vi har en kompetens kring hur du sköter allt det här.
Så du kan ju höra av det även om du har köpt skor av en konkurrent och vi hjälper du ska lösa dem om du har fått ett problem.
Och då tror jag många hör av sig till oss för att de vet att det är vi som är vassast på skor.
Ja jag förstår, vi ska komma tillbaks till hela det här, hur man bygger sitt varumärke och hur ni sticker ut och liknande.
Men först måste vi ha en intro om Emil också och vem du är.
Bara så att folk får någon sorts, det är inte bara Skolix idag, det är också Emil.
Vem är Emil?
Väldigt kort, jag är lite över 40, fru, barn, gillar fotboll, rave, business, resa.
Ja, det lät ju väldigt generiskt.
Har du några udda intressen som sticker ut?
Det är väl att jag gillar, ibland då när, nu har man ju barn och är inne i hela den svängen som vi pratade om innan här också.
Så då åker vi ibland, jag och fru igen, på sådana här ultra music festival då.
Då kör man i tre dagar i hjärnet och så kan man vila ett år sedan till nästa gång.
Det gör väl lite alla kanske.
Det känns inte som ett standard svar, nej.
Hur länge sedan var det ni var på en sådan?
Det var förra sommaren då.
Jaha, oj.
Det är bra jobbat.
Vem tog ungarna?
Det blev faktiskt så att barnvaktnen blev sjuk två dagar innan.
Så de fick vara med.
Så Lisa som du träffade här borta, hon fick åka med ner.
Jaha, alltså ni tog med ungarna och så tog du med en anställd som fick passa ungarna medan ni drog på någon sorts all black out i tre dygn.
Ja men det var ju på nätterna bara då.
Jo, jo, jo.
Så det blir ju speciellt men jag tycker det är kul.
Så du menar att ni var pigga och glada på dagen och fokuserade på era vana, absolut.
Fan vad roligt, det var ju sjukt random.
Jag uppskattar det, jag tycker alltid att det är kul när folk är lite twister i bakgrunden liksom.
Vi ska inte fastna i dina partyvanor för att det kanske sägs någonting här som är dåligt för företaget så vi håller oss på företagsspåret.
Kan du ta oss tillbaka till när du slutade med mobilskal och sidotillbehör och allt sånt där och bara bestämde dig för att nu ska jag in på skor och hur det året såg ut eller de åren såg ut när du liksom drog igång detta bolaget.
Ja, det här med mobilskal och sådana grejer, det var ju väldigt länge sedan, det var ju gymnasietiden då men sen så var det alltid haft intresse av lite sådana här olika e-handels, följde mycket de här, Dan Nilsson, Joel och de här när de drog igång Partykungen och roliga prylar och allt sånt där.
Och just då höll jag på och då var det skotillbehör och jag vet att jag köpte, skulle köpa present till min farsa som alltid har varit ganska skointresserad och beställde lite saker på nätet och mejlade, kom ihåg och frågade hur, om jag skulle hinna få ditt hans födelsedag, och då fick jag till svar av den butiken då att kanske, och då kände jag liksom, här finns det lucka då, dels med kvalitet på produkterna och sen har jag alltid sett, jag har alltid testat olika saker och sådana här saker som att alltid leverera dagen efter, svarar snabbt på kundtjänst, att du alltid får svar direkt och lite sådana saker och så att, jag kände väl att det fanns en potential där och började testa då och märkte, det var inte snabbt skulle jag säga men jag märkte att jag fick i lite traction iallafall så att det kändes roligt nog att köra vidare på det.
Vad var det för produkter från början och hur satte du igång liksom?
Ja då var det väldigt smalt, det var skoblock och skokrämor och lite borstar och så egentligen.
Väldigt smalt, kanske var en 10-20 produkter bara från början.
Men var det någon annans produkter du sålde då eller var det egen produktion eller?
Det var både egna och andras, 50-50 ungefär.
För idag är en överväljande majoritet av er sortiment, era egna produkter känns det som?
Ja, vi har väldigt mycket eget men också andra märken.
Så framförallt när det kommer till skokrämor så finns det Safir som vi har stora då.
Och sen även på skor har vi ett par andra märken som Janko, Telby och så, men mycket eget också.
Och hur tog ni fram era första skor?
När man hör folk i sådana här poddar så känns det alltid som att de pratar om att det är så krångligt att ta fram skor.
Är det så krångligt att ta fram skor?
Ja men det är krångligt, framförallt om man är ny och inte kan.
Och vi hade ju förmånen då att jobba med en butik länge, eller en fabrik rättare sagt, innan.
Där jag blev väldigt god vän med han som drev den fabriken och sen när han startade egen fabrik så hackade vi på där.
Och då blev det också där vi gjorde våra första egna skor då.
Där vi fortfarande gör än idag då.
Vad var det stora, för mig som inte vet, för mig är det bara en sko, en sko, jag fattar inte vad det krångliga är, det är lite läder och det är en suna typ.
Vad är det krångliga med en sko?
Nej men det är egentligen inte så mycket krångligt, men det som skiljer våra skor om man då tänker på de randsydda skorna, som är de lite finare skorna om man säger så, det är ju att om du tittar här på den här skon vi har bredvid oss här, så ser du att den är sydd här runt.
Man kan säga att själva sulan, de har sytt ner i sulan runt skon.
Ja så kan man säga, vilket gör att det billigaste att göra är att ta en sko och limma ihop allting.
Du limmar ihop ledret med sulan och allting och så bär du den och när den spricker då kan skommakan kanske ha något superlimma och limma ihop den en liten tid tills den håller ett halvår och sen så är den körd.
Medan de här kan du ha i tio år utan problem om du sköter om dem lite och att skommakan kan sula om dem och säga om dem.
Vilket gör att det är en mycket dyrare konstruktion.
Så det är väl lite utmaningen att kunna kommunicera det till dem som inte är insatta.
Att betalar du lite mer så får du betydligt mycket mer.
Det är som min vän har lyckats lära dig att han har inte råd att köpa billiga skor längre.
För han förstår att de håller i många år.
Jag köper ju nya skor varje år.
För mina går ju sönder.
För jag köper ju dem som står på rean.
Så när jag går härifrån då ska jag börja köpa sådana här skor.
Det går emot hela min personlighet.
De på lagret kommer att mobba mig när jag kommer ut med sådana här grejer.
Okej, jag förstår.
Okej, så det är själva hantverket i sig som är lite knepigt kanske.
Och sen gissar jag att det är väldigt mycket detaljer.
Nu ser ju inte alla de som lyssnar.
Alla skor ser ju väldigt olika ut i designen.
Även om en sko ser ut som en sko så ser de ju väldigt olika ut.
Är det det som är det krångliga?
Är det framtagning av produkten som är det krångliga?
Nummer ett skulle jag säga är ju material.
Vilka material du väljer.
För där är det självklart vad du väljer för material.
Du kan välja det som är lättast att tillverka med.
Eller det som är bäst, både hållbarhet och komfort.
Ofta är det inte det som är billigast.
Chokerande.
Till exempel om man tar hälen som kanske alla kan förstå.
Där har vi läder eller pressat läde.
Sliptam kan man säga i hälen.
Men det är mycket vanligare att göra med plast.
Då blir hälen stenhård.
Det är väldigt hållbart med stenhård plasthäll.
Men det är inte så skönt då.
Det är svårare att göra, det är dyrare att göra.
Det är något man behöver baka in i priset och kunna förmedla till kunderna.
En finess och att folk förstår vinsten med det.
Vad är detaljen på en sko som gör att den blir en premium sko?
Finns det någon detalj som man ofta kan se att det där är en bra sko?
Är det den här sydda grejen?
Mycket är att det är randsydda skor.
Sen finns det ju jättefina skor som inte är randsydda också.
Men om du har ett par randsydda skor och träffar någon annan som har det, då vet man i regel att man har lite koll på läget.
Finns det någon annan detalj som är såhär, det här är bara de där som verkligen bryr sig om skor.
Är det såhär, skosnörerna blänker i mångljuset.
Finns det någon udda detalj som man inte hade kunnat tänka sig?
Det är också något man ser att man kan göra något på tårn, som man kallar en spitshine.
Tårn är helt spitt.
Det är ju som militärer gjorde, att de putsade kängorna.
Så tårn verkligen glänste då.
Och det kan man göra också då.
Så möter du någon som har det, då har de suttit x antal timmar.
Det är ingenting man kan producera, utan du måste verkligen putsa dina skor.
Ja, man måste göra det och framförallt underhålla det om det ska se fint ut med tiden.
Då vet man, det där är någon som lägger tid på det där.
Exakt.
Okej, jag förstår.
Vi ska inte fastna helt i skorna.
Men när du började sälja skor, för att någon gång tog du in dina första skor och började sälja dem, vilka var de första skorna och hur fick du folk att börja köpa de skorna via nätet?
Just då var det en skoboom kan man säga.
Det fanns ett intresse inom det här menswear, kallas det då, de som är kläd och skointresserade.
Vart är vi i tiden nu?
Bra fråga.
Någon gång, för några år sedan.
Kan det vara sju, åtta år sedan runt det.
Kan det vara 2016, 2017 möjligtvis.
Vi säger att det var det.
Ja, och då fanns det ett intresse kring det här.
Men idag är marknaden helt annorlunda, men då fanns ett fåtal klassiska skottillverkare, många från England, som jobbade genom butiker.
Då hade vi en grossist, en agent och en butik.
Det var prisvärt men kanske lite högre priser.
Då började det komma internationellt många olika märken som började sälja.
Vi fick kontakt med ett märke på Mallorca som hette Janko.
Därifrån köpte vi in våra åtta första modeller.
Det var tillräckligt känt som varumärke då?
Det var inte alls särskilt känt, men just det här designen och konstruktionen gjorde att kom det ett nytt märke som var ansidd av och som såg ut på rätt sätt då skapar intresse.
Jag kommer ihåg att vi hade en sån franschö i Göteborg och man hade ingen aning vad som förväntade sig.
Vi fick ställa upp folk på kölistan för att det var så många som kom och ville prova för att det var inte så tillgängligt på den tiden.
Det är ganska fort.
Det svänger väldigt fort, eller vad man ska säga.
Nu känns det extremt tillgängligt.
Nu är det ju supertillgängligt och mycket lättare att starta också än det var då.
Idag kan du i princip gå till en fabrik och peka vad du vill ha för färg på skokartongen och vilka modeller du vill ha så är det ju bara att beställa.
Vad tillverkas skor någonstans?
Vi tillverkar ju mycket på Mallorca då.
Okej.
Både av våra egna och andra då.
Sen är det ju inte så många som tillverkar på Mallorca längre då.
Vi gör ju det men många är på Spanien eller Portugal mycket också.
Varför Mallorca?
Det finns en sån hantverkstradition där, framförallt i Inca då, inne på Mallorca.
Där det finns mycket historik inom läderarbete men också av skor.
Men det är ju de som gör i Europa då.
Sen görs det ju mängder i Asien också men det finns ju...
Det är mer mina skor?
Ja men även det har ju börjat komma andra också som kanske då köper en läder i Europa så skickar de det till en fabrik i Asien som gör skorna och skickar tillbaka dem då.
Det är som med allt annat.
Ni har ju en extremt linjär tillväxtkurva.
Det är ju som en liten trappa, det är ju trevligt när det ser ut sådär.
Vad är det som, för detta är väl ändå någon sorts trend-svär.
Detta måste ju ändå vara en bransch som dels har ni utsatts för massa konkurrenter som har kommit in i den här marknaden.
Vi har haft lågkonjunktur, vi har haft corona.
Ni är ett nytt märke får man säga.
Ni är inte en etablerad aktör som har haft hjälp av andra grejer.
Så det är lite udda att ha den trappstegsformen på omsättningen.
Och ni har alltid gått med vinst.
Kan du förklara lite hur ni har lyckats med den här prestationen?
Från början körde vi på med skovård och skotillbehör.
Sen kom det naturligt att öka med skor.
Skor och skovård kan man hålla på med till en viss gräns.
Men sen har det kommit så mycket längre.
Så då började vi med skor och där blir det helt plötsligt på enligt mycket större värld.
Där höll vi på mycket med dressade skor, kom med nyheter och utvecklade nya skor och tog in nya och så där.
Sen kom ju corona och då tvingades man tänka om lite för att attrahera nya målgrupper och när folk inte var på kontoret längre.
Det jag tycker att vi var snabba på pucken är att anpassa oss till det.
Vilket har gjort att sen även efter då kan vi liksom, då har vi fler kunder att vända oss till.
Vi har ju både de kanske lite mer casual och de är dressade som nu har fått fart igen då.
Finns det inte en fara där i att man vänder sig mot båda grupper?
Vill inte de som är dressade, vill inte de vara ett eget segment?
Är de fine med att man helt plötsligt säljer mindre dressade skor?
Ja men jag förstår vad du menar och jag tror de som har koll, vi har ju skor från egentligen 1500 upp till 6000.
Och de som köper för 6000, de vet ju i regel vad de betalar för.
Vi har ju en topplinje som de som köper den vet att det är väldigt mycket skog för pengarna.
Så de vet ju vad det är de betalar för och köper.
Så att jag upplever att man har såpass bra koll att det är inget problem för dem.
För det vi säljer som är billigare, kanske sniker som är instegsskorna kan man säga, de har så hög specification och kvalitet så att även om du gillar dem för 6000 och kollar på dem för 1500 så förstår du att den typen av skor är riktigt, riktigt bra.
Bra sko.
Det är ett fint svar men det besvarar inte lite varför ni har vuxit år för år.
Ni har utvecklat sortimentet och ni har släppt om riktigt snabbt.
Men varför går ni med vinst hela tiden?
Detta måste ju vara en svår bransch som alla andra.
Det är definitivt inte alla som går med vinst i denna branschen.
Nej men vi har dels varit försiktiga både på gott och ont.
Skryt nu.
Tänk på att detta är en podd där man får snacka gott.
Jag vet att du är i Göteborgs, men känn dig i Stockholmski idag.
Nej men vi har varit försiktiga med investeringar både på gott och ont, vilket har gjort att nu när vi har börjat komma i kapp då, kanske de senare åren, då har vi alltid haft något chansprojekt också, så att vi har börjat ösa på lite mer när det gäller marknadsföring och olika.
Vi brukar ta in någon expert inom något område, det kan vara någon form av marketing eller PR eller någonting som vi rullar ett tag med och sen så switchar vi för att försöka tillgodose de städerna vi kan öka på.
Sen är det utanför Sverige också.
Det började ju bara i Sverige och nu börjar vi växa internationellt också.
Så det är både sortimentberedning men även att vi växer på nya marknader också.
Jag är halvnöjd med svaret.
Har du inga hemliga knep här till varför du lyckas ligga på ett positivt resultat?
Vad är det ni satsar, jag vill ju gräva lite här.
Jag vill ju sticka ut här lite grann i poddvärlden så att vi inte bara blir den här, ja vi fokuserar på ett långsiktigt segment och en breddning och sånt.
Vafan, skit i det nu.
Jag ska inte svära för mycket i podden.
Men liksom, vad är det ni lägger pengar på?
Vad är det ni inte lägger pengar på?
Det är lite som när det kommer till skorna också.
När du köper skor och såhär så betalar du för skorn.
Och väldigt lite overhead.
Samma skor kan kosta dubbelt hos någon annan där du betalar jättemycket för marknadsföring och PR och de sakerna.
Men vi är en väldigt slimmad organisation.
Vi är ju fortfarande ungefär tre heltidsanställda.
Och vi har ju många andra, kanske i samma storlek 8-10 anställda.
Men då har ni ett tredjepartslager kanske?
Ja, ett tredjepartslager har vi som skett det.
Och sen är jag ju väldigt tekniskt intresserad.
Mycket är automatiserat och strömmlinjeformat.
Så vi har ju inga höga urhöljdkostnader heller.
Hur får ni in era kunder?
Mycket är ju folk som rekommenderar varandra.
Vi kan se i ett land att en produkt plötsligt boomar.
Då ser man ju, då är det ofta att folk har tipsat andra.
Det var några veckor sedan då började det ringa en massa från Östermalm för att deras barn skulle ha våra skor.
Då har det spridit sig att någon skulle ha en viss typ av skor.
Så det är ju mycket också genom att folk tipsar varandra.
Men sen är det också det traditionella med Google och Facebook eller Meta och de vägarna.
För alla konkurrenter som tänkte att nu jävlar ska vi få inputten på hur de tjänar pengar här och fortsätter växa så slimma ner i er organisation och bli rekommenderade.
Det kanske är tråkigt men vi har ju inga investerare som trycker på att vi ska växa på ett visst ställe.
Det är väl både på gott och ont också.
I och med att det är våra egna pengar så är det också att gör vi något riskfyllt så är det ju indirektens egen kassare som kommer ifrån så därför är vi väldigt försiktiga med vad vi gör och ser till.
Sen kanske vi har varit för försiktiga och anställt för långsamt ibland att vi borde ta ett steg framåt och rekrytera i förväg i stället för efterhand och så där.
Men ja, vi har inga direkta onödiga, jag kan inte se någonting vi har som onödigt.
Tvärtom så borde vi börja ta in lite mer.
Jag fattar precis vad du menar.
Vi kör på samma sätt.
Folk får lära sig först och sen när man märker att det här funkar inte, då får man ta in någon ny, jag fattar precis.
Men sen tror jag också att det handlar om att bygga en skalbar modell från början som jag hade inte vetat om vi hade gått med förlust första fem åren, hur man skulle vända det i så fall.
Det är väl att den affärsmodellen vi satte från början har fungerat genom alla år egentligen och den kör vi vidare på.
Det är ju en affärsmässigt hållbar modell, känner jag.
Den kommer ju att funka ännu bättre om vi dubblar vår omsättning, vilket vi hoppas göra på några år.
Då kommer vi få skalfördelar av det snarare än att det är tvärtom.
Det blir svårare.
Kan vi inte prata lite grann om, du är väl ensam ägare till bolaget.
Vad är fördelarna med det och vad är nackdelarna med det?
Fördelen är ju att man kan bestämma, i teorin kan man ju bestämma allting själv och ta alla beslut själv, vilket jag tycker är skönt.
Sen har jag aldrig testat motsatsen heller, så det är ju mycket väl att det kan finnas en massa fördelar med att ha någon annan som hjälper till också.
Vet du något beslut som du har tagit som du tror att det här beslutet hade nog inte en investerare tagit, men du tog det i alla fall för att det kändes rätt.
Ja men det är ju inköp och sådana saker kan det vara att vissa tjänster som hade någon utifrån kanske tyckte att det var helt hål i huvudet att lägga det på det.
Men det är ju inte så att vi bränner massa pengar heller på något som är helt galet liksom.
Så att snarare kanske det är att de skulle tyckte att vi hade spenderat mer på vissa områden, men känner inte vi att det är helt säkert investering så kanske vi är hellre avvaktar.
Sen nackdelen är väl att precis som när det går bra, även när det går dåligt eller när det händer saker, så är det ju ens egna kassa också då.
Hur ser du på, drivs du av att nu ska jag bygga ett bolag som jag tycker om att jobba i, eller drivs det av att nu ska vi ha tillväxt i detta bolaget, eller drivs det av att om man går investerarrouten så är det ju kanske väldigt mycket snabb tillväxt som man är ut efter, eller någon sorts exit eller liknande.
Bygger man själv kanske det handlar mer om att jag ska bygga detta på sikt eller detta ska bli min stora.
Sen kan man drivas av tillväxt där också.
Men vilka är liksom grunddrivkrafterna?
Du har ändå gjort detta bolaget ett tag, vad är det du hoppas på?
Jag hoppas att vi ska fortsätta växa och nu har vi ju, det här med investerare kanske hade varit också lite annorlunda om vi kände att vi stod och stampade och inte utvecklades eller växte längre om den där trappan hade stannat av.
Men så länge vi känner det så har vi en modell som jag tycker fungerar och det man drivs av är att fortsätta se till att vi växer.
Och sen så är vi ju nu på en nivå mitt emellan kan man säga, vi börjar bli några stycken men hade vi fått in lite mer folk, fyra, fem pers till på kontoret, så hade det också blivit en roligare dynamik tror jag.
Att det blir lite mer riktiga roller, folk behöver, jag gör ju fortfarande väldigt mycket olika saker, men man hade kunnat ha lite mer renoverade roller, som jag tror folk hade tyckt var kul på kontoret också då.
Så att bygga ett lite mer riktigt bolag på ett par års sikt.
Ja, jag gillar det.
Jag upplever att alla alltid tänker att de vill bygga ett riktigt bolag, men man kommer liksom aldrig, ja, jag upplever fortfarande att vi har ett skämtbolag till, eller du vet så här, det är typ lite på skoj.
Och jag snackade med någon här i podden för några månader sedan, de omsatte väl 130, 140, 150 miljoner och de är också fortfarande bara på skoj.
Alla går bara runt och tänker att de har ett skämtbolag och tänker att om vi dubblar då är vi på riktigt.
Det blir fan aldrig på riktigt.
Det är Volvo och Ikea, alla andra är bara posers.
Men om man är en till i Volvo kan man ju ändå kanske börja locka till sig, blir lättare iallafall att ha folk som har renodlade expertrolle kanske.
Nu hyr vi in en hel del kompetens för att vi har ett hundraprocent beläggning för någon som sitter med SEO eller någon som sitter med ads utan då får någon göra det på teambasis liksom.
Men det hade ju varit på sikt bra att ha det i inhouse, att ha kompetens och heltidsrolle för vissa saker.
Vad ligger din kompetens någonstans?
Vad är det du känner att det här är jag jävligt duktig på?
Jag har bra koll på IT och businessen skulle jag vilja säga.
Att det är där mina starka sidor är och mycket av vi handlar ner i IT både när det gäller allt ifrån vad du ska ha för plattform till vad du ska ha för betallösningar och kopplingar.
Så är vi ganska nördiga och detaljindriktade på det och att få ihop det med businessen så att det blir affärsmässigt hållbart.
Hur mycket anser du att det här runtomkring spelar roll för att ni ligger som sagt i ett premiumsegment och om du vill gå in på en hemsida kräver ett premiumsegment en viss betallösning, kräver ett premiumsegment en viss fraktlösning.
Behöver man tänka på alla de där grejerna eller är det produkten i sig som fortfarande är det viktiga?
Jag tror att det finns en lägsta nivå där och nu har vi i år bytt lager i år.
Vilket var en sån stor puckel men jäkligt skönt att ha gjort.
Så nu kan vi bjuda allting med paket, började vi med Instabox och allting, hemleveranser och allting.
Så där finns ju inget att anmärka på längre.
Men visst innan hade vi bara på snod och det kan ju vara lite så att du inte kan välja.
Så att ja det är ju sådant vi ska ha och leveransdagen efter du beställer och sådär.
Men ni har inga såhär udda tilläggstjänster typ att här du får dina skor inslagna i ett gult papper och en person som lämnar över det med en kram.
Gult papper hade vi faktiskt på test som vi drog in, men det var ju en som ville ha det på ett år tror jag.
Det var väldigt många som frågade innan om det, fin inslagning och så, men sen var det ingen som ville beställa det.
Så att vi har testat det men nej men det är att få skorna av hög kvalitet snabbt levererade.
Det är det.
Ja men det är väl rimligt.
Och jag gissar att det måste vara lite av en pengning där så att byta lager när man jobbar med skor för att för den utavstående är det ju bara lådor och det är lite olika storlekar.
Det är ganska svårt att öppna en låda om man inte känner till och se vad det är för sorts skor.
Hur smidigt gick lagerflytten?
Det gick bättre än jag trodde men det är klart, det är precis som du säger att vi har ju också vuxit från att ha skickat 20 paket i månaden på första 3PL som vi hade till att skicka några tusen paket idag.
Så det blir en helt annan komplexitet när det ska in streckkoder och man inte har grundat med streckkoder från början.
De nya som jobbar på lagret ska förstå texterna på kartongen och sådär.
Så det är klart att det har varit en del att rätta upp och en del fortsatt kvar att rätta upp.
Är det att skor hamnar fel då eller är det att...
Ja det kan ju vara en sån liten detalj att vi kan ha samma skor med två olika suler till exempel.
Okej, ja.
En är leder och en är gummi då och då ska de hamna på olika lagerplatser men...
Nästan allt är fixat nu.
Men sen är det ju även leverantörer att när det gäller streckkoder då till exempel så kan man ju hitta på egna bara i något sånt här verktyg medan vi nu då har skaffat riktiga GS-nummer.
Så att man framtidssäkrar på det sättet också.
Det kan ju komma från Google, det vet man inte.
Det helt plötsligt kommer ju i alla fall på många av våra märkesprodukter och att det var tvunget att finnas för att de skulle synas på Google.
Så därför framtidssäkrar vi det med våra egna också nu, även om det inte behövs egentligen.
Ja, jag förstår.
Vi har gjort en samma resa så att det blir en del märkliga fel och det kan ju även bli en del märkliga fel i översättningen.
Vi har liksom skrivit namnen på våra produkter och vi gjorde stretchmattor till exempel av en viss modell och då ville vi ha en hängare för den mattan.
Då skrev vi till producenten att we want the hanger for the mat above.
Då trodde de att det var namnet på produkten så det står på lådan, so hanger for the mat above.
Man vet ju inte vad som, det finns massa skumma grejer och det fattar ju de på lagret men kommer det en ny person är det ju väldigt svårt för dem att förstå att den lådan är den lådan.
Den har inte sitt namn, den har en konstig text på sig.
Nej och samtidigt är det ju, nu håller vi på att växla lite personal också, en som ska börja, en som ska sluta så att det får en också att reagera lite positivt skulle jag säga för att man fattar vad det är man måste styra upp som är grundläggande, att vissa saker behöver förenklas för att det inte ska bli för komplext.
Finns det en, gruppmentalitet i skovärlden, när ni kom in som nya aktör och ni skulle etablera er, fanns det lite skitsnack i den här världen?
Ja, här kommer de med sina skor, tror de att de skorna är bra eller?
Nej, inte skitsnack, sluta säga.
Sen är det ju klart att många, på den tiden var det ju väldigt mycket olika, att det kom ett märke från en fabrik och så kom det ett märke från en annan.
Idag är det ju en helt annan, där är det ju många märken som görs i samma fabrik, men gemene man vet ju inte det.
Nu vet jag ju att våra skor, våra fabriker är våra och så gör de några till, men ingen som direkt konkurrerar med oss då.
Medan, så det är ju det som kanske är lite utmaningen att kunna förmedla på ett sätt med integritet fortsatt, att kunna berätta vad det är man säljer och vad det är för produkter, utan att kanske överdriva vad det är man säljer.
Kan ni se när det kommer en ny aktör, jag tänker att det är lite grann, det fanns ju en trend när alla startade mobilskal.
Det var ju det i början, och sen fanns det ju den trenden när alla killar mellan 22 och 27 skulle starta klockmärken.
Det låg ju inte åtta butiker i veckan på Blocket som skulle säljas med det.
Och nu känns det som att de senaste åren så har det varit ganska många som ville in i det här skosegmentet.
Det känns som lite, jag vet inte om trendigt är rätt ord, men det känns som att det finns lite status i att ha ett eget varumärke inom skor och sådär.
Kan du se när de lanserar att det där är ingen riktig sko och så vill du skriva upp det på deras hemsida men du kan inte riktigt, är det?
Ja men det är...
Kan du känna en bitterhet över att gemene man inte fattar att det där är ingen riktigt bra sko?
Både och, för det jag kan känna är ju att vi behöver bli bättre på att förmedla det hur bra våra är, samtidigt så är det en fin gräns.
Till skitsnack.
I skor så har det även traditionellt och historiskt varit mycket att man pratar om handgjorda skor.
Det beror ju på vad man definierar, det är ju en definitionsfråga.
Det är som om din podd är denna handgjord, för att du tryckte på datorn här när du spelade in.
Jag tycker inte det då.
Men en sko när den är handgjord, vi har ju några handgjorda skor som görs, en typ av kängel som görs, riktigt för hand då.
Men de här andra är ju randsida då, det är ju maskin som syr.
Vi kallar inte det handsyt, medan sådana annan har det i sina annonser, att de här är made by hand.
Då är det klart att man kan känna att, och när vi också då får kunder som inte är initierade, som undrar, är era skor också handgjorda, för jag jämför det här.
Och då ska man liksom ställa sig och förklara den saken då.
Men ofta brukar vi, jag brukar ha den approachen, vi ställer gärna båda, och om du har den bredvid varandra och tycker att om du kan motivera varför en annan skor är bättre, så bjuder jag operaturen, då kan du skicka tillbaka dem.
Och hittills har ingen återkommit någonsin med det.
Så att man får försöka, det är ju det som är utmaningen, att framhäva sina egna skor utan att ta till, liksom att överdriva och fara med osanning.
För där vill vi hålla, genom vår expertkunskap vill vi hålla hög integritet på det.
Ja, såklart.
Man vinner väldigt länge den men det är ju frustrerande ibland kanske.
Ja, det ska vi erkänna att det är.
Köper det.
Hur ser hela returbusinessen ut?
Är det mycket retur eller är det irriterande retur?
Sådär, ah det är en liten blodfläck där bak, den kan vi inte sälja igen.
Ja, i vissa fall är det det.
Men jag skulle säga att för att vara i skor så tycker vi det har, jag tycker vi är bra på det.
Om man ser med skor och även att vi har, vi har ju olika kategorier av skor.
Adressade, har du en dressad så kan vi rekommendera dig alla andra adressade och veta vilken storlek du ska ha egentligen.
Sen kan det vara när du testar en u-modell som en sniker eller en viss lo, för då kan du ju diffa i storlek.
Men sen är det också vad vissa anser är provat, att man går ut en kväll på stan och sen känner att den skavde lite.
Så det är ju en balansgång där, man får ju hantera det individuellt.
Hur snälla är ni?
Vi är hyfsat snälla skulle jag säga, men det beror ju på vem du frågar också.
Det är klart att det är väldigt olika också.
Vi kan ju ha folk som har anmärkningar.
Våra skor ligger ju mellan 1500 och 6000.
Min kollega som är skornörd köper skor för upp mot 50 000 ibland.
Det är rimligt.
Jag tror han har sagt att han aldrig hittat någon som är helt flåless liksom.
Men ofta så kanske du är van att köpa skor för 1500 här i Sverige då.
Så köper du ett par från oss för 3000 så förväntar du att de ska vara 100% felfria.
Och det finns ingen skor för 3000 som är 100%.
När du säger felfri, vad är det som är fel?
Det kan vara att du har någon synpunkt på något litet märke.
Det kan vara att ta upp en skog här och visa dig, men här är en liten liten.
Okej, det är liksom en skiftning.
Jag skulle säga att det är ett dammkorn, men jag är ju inte den kunde då.
Okej, jag fattar.
Det skulle kunna vara en skiftning i lädret på en viss punkt.
Ja, på en viss punkt.
Man har sett ju ofta lädebitarna, om det är ett litet märke, försöka sätta det på insidan, för att du kan inte kassera allt läde.
Det hade liksom varit ekonomiskt försvarbart.
Det är inget som vi betalar för det i den här nivån, att ha en felfri skor, utan då får du ju gå upp i prisklass.
Så det är därför vi har skor också uppåt.
Men då är det också att utbilda och få folk att förstå vad du kan förvänta dig för en viss prisnivå.
Vi hade ju kunnat göra mycket mer för elfria skor och öka priset.
Men är det sådana grejer som folk irriterar sig på?
Det är det som är.
Är det en vanlig...
Jag utifrån kan ju tycka att det där inte är en grej, men är det det folk anmärker på mest?
Vissa är anmärkningar med rätta.
Det är klart att fabrikerna kan göra fel och missa i kvalitetskontrollen.
Men det lättaste är om de inte använder dem, då är det bara att byta ut dem.
Det är lite större utmaning när folk har hittat en prick efter en vecka på dem.
Men det kan vara sådana här saker och där det kan skilja lite.
Jag fattar, lustigt.
Det är ju någon sorts organiskt material och då är det alltid svårt.
Det kan ju inte vara extremt jämn färg över hela gitan, det kommer alltid vara någon skiftning någonstans.
Det är som ett trä.
Ja det är ju leder och det är ju också lite, nu vet jag att det kanske blir för djupgårda här.
Nej, ingenting är för nödigt, köp på nu bara.
Men när det gäller leder då, det är ju en av, när det gäller skor då, att få tag i bra leder.
För det hänger ihop, allt leder är ju överskott efter köttproduktion egentligen, det som går till mat.
Men då är det ju också det som är fördelen med våra skor skulle jag säga, är ju att ledret är ju från Europa.
Och för att ledet ska vara bra, om du kollar på den skorna här till exempel så ser du inte mycket märken, men det betyder ju också att djuren måste ha det bra.
Eller relativt bra då, att de inte får gå för tätt, de får liksom inte få några märken från...
Ja för då blir det sår.
Då blir det sår och de får inte växa för fort, för då får du bristningar och mycket vener och sånt i lädret.
Det är också en aspekt av det här, att det är under relativt även europeiska djurskyddslager och sådär, eftersom lädret är från Europa.
Men det är också utmanande då att det blir svårare och svårare och dyrare och dyrare att få tag i fint läder då.
Okej, intressant.
Det kanske är det mest omtyckta avsnittet i den här podden, men vet folk kanske verkligen läde sig någonting där?
Jag hoppas det.
Det är bra.
När du tog in din första anställd, när var det och var fanns det liksom, hade du en aktiv arbetsintervju då eller blev det bara att du tog in en person och hade tur eller letade efter vissa egenskaper?
I början körde jag ju allting själv och sen fick jag ta in lite hjälp när jag var föräldraledig och så där mest jobba nätter och så.
Då tog jag in lite killar som jag lärde känna via skolvärden egentligen.
Sen min första riktiga anställd blev faktiskt Jesper, min skolkollega, som var här och testade skor med en kompis och så sa han på skoj typ om jag hade något jobb till henne.
Så började vi prata lite löst om det och sen blev det så.
Och det har funkat sedan dess?
Ja, det har funkat sedan dess.
Han är kvar än.
Det är skönt när det funkar så.
Jag tycker ofta att det är så mycket snack om vad man letar efter för anställd, hur viktigt det är att man får in rätt anställda och det är det ju.
Men det känns som att man har tur.
Ja, man behöver ha det.
När du tänker på framtiden här inom nyanjongen, ni säljer lite utomlands, hur mycket är utomlands till exempel?
Jag har inte kollat exakt, man skulle säga 10-20% utomlands runt där.
Vad är de närmsta fem åren här?
Vad är era fokusområden?
Vart är det du tror ni kommer växa?
Vad är det du tänker på på kvällarna när du ska gå och lägga dig?
Jag tror att vi kommer fortsatt växa mycket i Sverige.
Sen har vi ju Norden, jag ser att den storleken vi har i Sverige, där vi omsätter kanske 20 miljoner i Sverige då, gör vi det så borde vi kunna omsätta 10 i Norge och 10 i Danmark.
Sen har vi ju Tyskland och många sådana länder, där är det ju inte lika lätt att bara dra ut en annons på Google och klicka folk och köpa, utan där är det ju lite mer utmaningar att nå ut.
För det har vi testat.
Sen har vi gjort det fel, eller om Tyska och Google inte är lika lätt.
Så där tror vi att vi har stor potential att växa.
Vad är det ni gör när ni går in i en ny marknad?
Har ni någon metod som ni faktiskt kör på eller är det att vi drar ut en annons på Google?
Det beror på hur stor marknaden är och vad det är för språk också.
Vi kan ju öppna upp ett land bara för att de har mailar.
Det beror på vad det är att avse med att öppna ett land, men är det bara att öppna i kassan så är det bara att slå på fraktsetet.
Säg att ni faktiskt ska satsa lite på det landet.
Ni vill slå in en kilo och faktiskt komma igång.
När vi körde i Danmark då översätter vi hela sajten till danska och så fixar vi danska fraktset och danska betalssätt i kassan och så där.
Så det är ju en ganska stor process att dra igång i ett nytt land då.
Så då översätter vi ju automat, kör liksom AI-översättning och sedan anställer vi en journalist som kollar allt.
Inte allt men i ordning.
Och sen så drar ni igång marknadsföring ungefär som i Sverige.
Ja men exakt och hoppas att vi ska vara exakt som i Sverige.
Det är det ju inte oftast men det är väl det testet vi kör.
Men så er satsning de närmaste åren är att öppna mot mer länder, det är inte så mycket mer i Sverige.
Ja vi vill ju växa för vi ser ju att vi kan nå ut mycket mer i Sverige.
Och jag kan ju se...
Vad är det ni kan nå ut med då?
Ja men varumärkeskännedom skulle jag säga.
Att jag kan sitta såhär på tåget eller så så kan jag se någon som har schyssta skor bredvid.
Som nästan ser ut som våra, kan fråga vad de är ifrån.
Och de har ju...
Så kanske man börjar prata lite om ingen aning om vad skolyx är.
Så det är ju väldigt, väldigt många som inte vet vad skolyx är.
Samtidigt som fler och fler, jag kan höra såhär, någon kompis, kompis vet vad det är.
Men där känner vi att det finns ju enormt...
Det är ju fler som inte vet vilka vi är än vad som vet vilka vi är.
Hur bygger man varumärkeskännedom inom det segmentet?
Vart är det man ska synas eller vilka är det man syns med?
Det nischade segmentet, där tror jag vi syns väldigt mycket.
Där vet de flesta de som är skointresserade vet vilka vi är.
Men sen är det ju att nå ett steg till och ett steg till.
Det är väl som er, alla träningsfreaks vet ju säkert vilka ni är, men sen kanske lite lika självklart för...
Ann 47 i...
Nej, om hon ska köpa några hantlar liksom.
Kanske om köper de på Biltema eller...
Men så att det är väl där att nå ett steg till utanför för att sko...
Den nischade skovärlden kan du ju knappt leva på liksom, utan du måste ju nå ett steg längre ut.
Men hur gör ni för att nå dem?
Vad har du för planer där eller för tankar där eller...
Mycket jobbar vi med utbildning, att vi har guider och informativt, att vi hjälper folk hur man ska sköta om sina skor, hur de ska se bra ut.
Vi jobbar mycket också med inte fotvård, men fothälsa.
Ta hand om dina skor, se till att de är i läder rakt igenom, så att de andas och inte svettas om fötterna hela dagarna.
Vi har guider för hur du sköter om dina skor, även om de inte är från oss, hur du håller dem fräsa.
På så sätt hittar vi folk också.
Vi har ju många som bara mailar och ringer och ber om tips och råd om skovård.
Ni vill bli någon sorts expert inom det området, så det är hos er man hamnar när man söker där.
Ja men exakt.
Det måste ju finnas en fara där i hela den här chat-GPT-trenden att nu bara skriver man det där istället och så hamnar man inte hos er.
Hur tänker du kring en sån?
Jag upplever samma sak själv, att vet jag att jag kan vända mig till en expert, så gör jag ju det och pratar med det.
Nu har vi bara bytt, det här kanske blir en jättekonstig jämförelse, men vi har ju bytt till Fortnox precis till exempel.
Och många av supporten är ju super vassa, men jag vet en som är super vassa, då betalar jag gärna för hennes hjälp istället för att fråga FAQ eller sådär.
För vet man att det finns en riktig expert, så pratar jag fortfarande med den chat-GPT.
Jag ska inte kritisera här, fast lite ska jag kritisera för det är roligt.
För de som faktiskt ringer in till er eller som vill chatta med er eller maila och så där, det måste ju fortfarande vara nischkunden, alltså den lite nördigare.
Jag bara tänker, om du vill få en sån som mig då till exempel att komma över till er värld, jag kommer ju inte godla på hur jag tar hand om skor.
Har du någon tanke på hur man når ut till en sådan där tråkig kund, liksom att göra den till sin riktiga kund?
Finns det några sådana strategier?
Du behöver inte finnas en strategi av vad du tycker är intressant.
Dels kan det ju vara genom att man sortimentbräddar så att du hittar något hos oss som du inte hittar hos någon annan.
Det är ju en del att folk hittar till oss av något annat.
Ja.
Det är ju samma inom träning och hälsa och allting givetvis.
Det är alltid de kunderna som skulle behövas som är helt hoppliga som nu är ut till.
Jag bara tycker det är en intressant punkt för att det känns ju någonstans som kan man...
För jag köper ju skor på samma sätt som de där människorna som du säger.
Man går in och så klickar man bara.
Det är en väldigt enkel kund att få igenom och som kan betala för ett par skor och hade gärna gjort det.
Men kan man hitta den kunden så är det ju en väldigt...
Det är en kund som aldrig kommer att byta affär någonsin för att...
Nej och det ser vi.
Vi har ju många som är återkommande.
Jag slår sig också av det.
Det hade man aldrig trott innan när det var Instaggons skovård på Nyhetsmorgon.
Hur mycket kunde det?
Det är bara som allt till fullständigt på sajten.
Det är bara att rassla in beställningen.
Nu vet jag att du ofta kollar på Nyhetsmorgon, men det är Nyhetsmorgon lördag.
Då fattar man att det klientelet också, att det finns en sån stor mängd som vi inte alls hade.
De hade ju ingen aning om oss innan, utan vi gick ju bara in och rasslade in beställningen.
Och de är ju kvar, de kanske köpte ett skoblogg första gången.
Men vet ju, då får den leveransen dagen efter, vi svarar på en timme om de mejlar oss.
Och vet att här får jag superservice.
Ja men de har ju skor också, så kanske du testar skor nästa gång då.
Så det är ju, ja det är väl tråkigt så.
Men det är bara att nöta på, se till att alla blir supernöjda och se till att försöka nå ut genom ads och utbildning liksom.
Men ja exakt, det är ju mycket det här att man snackar med någon som snackar med någon och så är det sådär, ja.
Alltså det hör jag bara när det står 8 utlåkade farsor på en letflats.
Vad pratar folk om?
Antingen pratar de om sin cykel, eller så pratar de om typ sina skor.
Jag kan ju inte prata om något om det, så jag går och gungar min unge, men jag märker ju att det är så, det funkar liksom.
Ja, och det är, sen fördelen då är ju att vi har väldigt många kombinationer, så att det är ju inte så att vi har en skor utan kommer din kollega med ett par skor från oss, så kan du beställa dem i en annan färg i alla fall, så att ni inte går med samma skor allihop där på laget.
Ja, det är bra.
Känner ni mig stålheta?
Det är väl fått förfrågningar.
Ja, just att ha vissa som rör sig mellan kontor och produktion då, vill ha det men det är lite smalt än så länge.
Ja, då hade ni nog varit först i världen nästan.
Jag tänker att du har ju gjort den, du har ju kört detta ett par år.
Och som sagt det har ju ändå varit en väldigt fin tillväxtresa.
Den är ju väldigt linjär och alltid med vinst.
Men finns det några missar som du känner, ah, det där hade jag gjort annorlunda idag eller det där hade jag velat tweka lite grann om jag fick göra om det.
Lager är väl en sådan sak, lager är att alltid ha varor i lager.
Initialt var vi kanske bundna av kapitalbrist, att vi inte kunde ösa på med det vi kunde.
Men jag har ju väldigt sällan haft för mycket varor i lager, utan det är ju oftare vi står under här.
Sen är ju utmaningen med skor, det är ju väldigt kapitalintensivt.
Du kan ju ha skor i en viss stor, som inte säljer på ett år.
Har du då 150-200 modeller så är det väldigt mycket skor som står också.
Så det går ju inte att ösa på bara vi ställer in hur mycket som helst heller.
Men att säkra upp lagret snabbare hade ju varit, och sen även framtidssäkra alla system, så man vet att det här funkar för att skala.
Sen kanske man inte tänker på att det ska skala när man drar igång ett hobbyprojekt i början.
Det tror jag är en ganska nyttig lärdom som fler människor borde tänka på.
Om man ändå har inställningen på riktigt, att det här ska göra i några år, man verkligen vet vad man ska satsa, då behöver man ju kunna ha lite skala i det.
Vi har gjort många tillägg som är jobbiga, som vi borde ha gjort tidigt.
Sedan idag är marknaden, säger jag, mycket lättare att börja i rent tekniskt också.
Du kan ju gå in och kolla med ett verktyg, vad någon stor e-handlare använder för plattform, vad de har för betalläsning och vad de har för check-out-läsning.
Alltså kan du ju bara signa upp på någon plan, smål, och så kör du på och så är du igång på två dagar.
På vår tid var det ju mycket mer knacka och du fick koppla ihop olika betalläsningar med...
Det var ju mycket mer tekniskt utmanande att dra igång då.
Idag kan du ju hitta skalbara lösningar direkt.
Jag förstår.
Finns det på andra sidan några satsningar som du har gjort under de här åren som du känner att det där var fucking geni-drag?
Hur glad jag är att jag gjorde det där.
Under corona satsade vi ju, vi funderade lite, men det värsta som kan hända är att jag och alla känner att vi har skor för all framtid.
Det var väl lite så jag kände då.
Då satsade vi och beställde mycket skor från våra fabriker.
Både för att jag vet hur små vissa fabriker är, så jag ville inte att de heller skulle stå utan jobb så att alla drog i handbromsen.
Så då öste vi på så mycket vi kunde och beställde.
Så det gjorde ju att när det väl började finnas efterfrågan så hade vi hyfsat gott om skoren.
Tyvärr råkade vi ut för en stor stull där också.
Så det var ju extrem otyr.
Ja, den suger.
Hur hanterar man?
Vad stald de och hur hanterar man det där?
Ja men det var ju under corona som märkte vi att det i början blir mer, lite mer intresserad för casual och sneakers eller den biten.
Så då tänkte jag nu bara SV på, vi beställer massa sneakers nu.
Så när vi skulle få dem, kom ihåg då var jag laddad typ för att ladda upp dem eller räkna upp saldot i webbshopen.
Så ringde de bara och sa, ja du vet, du hörde vad som har hänt va?
Vilka ringde?
Nej det visste jag inte då.
Nej okej det var bara någon som ringde.
Jag har ingen aning vem det är liksom.
Nej de har snott allting i natt.
Då hade de gått in i lastbilen utanför lagret, eller på en sån här poliskontrollplats och tattat alla skorna.
Så det var ju en jävla smäll då.
Men viktig lärdom för senare då.
Ja vad sjukt, vad tråkigt.
Men då hade vi försäkring och sånt.
Så det var väl ändå tur i otrymme, men det var en väldigt mycket försäljning vi gick misstamma.
Men jag tror då var vi inte rädda för att gasa och äsa på och bara köpa in så mycket vi bara kunde.
Vi hade ju ändå, förutom den ställen, ganska gott ställt med skor när de började efterfrågas igen.
Yes, jag tror att vi tar och pausar av där.
Jag har lärt mig mer om skor idag än vad jag någonsin har lärt mig, och mer om läder.
Fantastiskt kul att få komma hit och se hela den här operationen och ni som är här.
Stort tack Emil.
Ja tack själv, kul att vara här.
Tack, hej.
Hej.
Så när jag går härifrån ska jag börja köpa sådana här skor.
Det går emot hela min personlighet.
De på lagret kommer att mobba mig när jag kommer ut.